STEPHANIE WONG: Hi,
everyone, and welcome.
I hope you're enjoying
Google Cloud Next '21.
I know this is
another virtual year.
But I'm hoping that today, I get
to bring some of my experiences
to life for you.
I'm going to be
talking about what
it was like to explore the six
layers of Google Cloud data
center security.
Now, you might be thinking of
lasers, night vision cameras,
and military-grade fences.
You're not too far
off because security
is one of the most critical
elements of our data center's
DNA and Google Cloud workloads.
With dozens of data
centers globally,
security operations
means managing
a massively complex network.
I was one of the rare
Googlers to visit one.
So I'm going to take
you on a journey
to the core of a data
center to show you
the six layers of
physical security designed
to thwart unauthorized access.
But first, I'll touch on Google
Cloud security philosophy
before I take you on that
journey to the core of the data
center.
And then we'll
touch on how you can
leverage that same
philosophy on Google Cloud.
And it's great to be here today.
My name is Stephanie Wong.
I'm a Cloud developer advocate.
And I've been creating
developer-focused content
for the last four
years or so here.
Of course, when I got the
chance to visit a data center
and make a film about it, I
jumped at the opportunity.
So let's go ahead and
dive right into it.
So in terms of
transparency, we're
very clear about our commitments
to customers about your data.
Rule number one-- your data
belongs to you, no one else.
We do not sell customer
data to third parties,
nor do we use it
for advertising.
Your data is your data.
Your data is also encrypted in
transit and at rest all times.
And you do not have
to ask for that.
And if you want, we
can give you ways
to add additional
encryption on top of that.
We also have explicit rules to
guard against insider access.
There is no back door to Google.
There's no secret
government access.
We take pride in our
international audits.
And we deliver
results on request.
These are the most
important roles
in our mission of
digital transformation.
It's giving you the trust that
you need to build great things.
So how can Google Cloud
help organizations
with their security?
Well, first, we provide
protection from threats
through a secure foundation
core infrastructure
that is designed, built, and
operated with security in mind.
Second, we provide customers
with a constantly expanding
array of controls
that they can use
to help meet policy, regulatory,
and business objectives.
And third, we work to meet our
compliance responsibilities
and provide capabilities
to make compliance easier
for customers.
But first, let's talk
about the protection
that you get from building on
our infrastructure foundation.
Our infrastructure doesn't
rely on any single technology
to make it secure.
Rather, we build security
through progressive layers that
deliver true defense in depth.
So our hardware is
Google-controlled, built,
and hardened.
Any application binary that
runs on our infrastructure
is deployed securely.
We do not assume any
trust between services.
And we use multiple mechanisms
to establish and maintain
trust.
Our infrastructure
was designed to be
multi-tenant from the start.
All identities,
users, and services
are strongly authenticated.
Data stored on
our infrastructure
is automatically
encrypted at rest
and distributed for
availability and reliability.
Any communications over the
internet to our Cloud Services
are also encrypted.
And the scale of
our infrastructure
allows us to absorb many
denial of service attacks.
We have multiple
layers of protection
that further reduce the
risk of any DDoS impact.
And finally, our operations
teams detect threats
and respond to incidents
24/7, 365 days a year.
We actually have a white paper
written on our infrastructure
design that goes into all
of these areas in much
more detail.
Other cloud providers might
describe a similar stack
of capabilities.
But the way that Google Cloud
approaches many of these,
in my opinion, is very unique.
So I had the chance to
visit a data center in 2019.
And I made a video
about my experience
that you should all check out.
I'll be sure to share the link.
But you can find it
at bit.ly/6layersdeep.
This was a huge project.
And it wasn't easy to
get approvals or even
step foot inside the premises.
But in my job at
Google, I spend my days
working with developers.
Our data centers are crucial
to the work that they do.
But most never actually set
foot inside a data center.
So as you can see here, there
is a huge amount of space
that our data centers span,
352,000 square feet, or 33,000
square meters.
And all in all, less
than 1% of Googlers
ever get to set foot inside.
So I was determined to make a
video because for close to two
decades, Google
has designed data
centers from the ground up.
Security has surfaced as one
of the most critical elements
of our DNA.
And it's part of our commitment
to keep our customers'
data safe, and not to
mention Google Cloud
now meets more than 45
regulatory requirements,
and growing.
Our products regularly undergo
independent verification
of their security, privacy,
and compliance controls,
achieving certifications,
attestations of compliance,
or audit reports against
these global standards.
This means that an
independent auditor
has examined the controls
present in our data centers,
infrastructure, and operations.
These certifications include
some of the most widely
recognized, internationally
accepted independent security
standards, including ISO/IEC
27001 for security controls,
ISO/IEC 27017 for
Cloud Security,
and ISO/IEC 27018
for cloud privacy
as well as AICP SOC 1, 2, and 3.
These certifications
are helping us
meet the demands of
the industry standards,
like CSA STAR and
PCI DSS as well
as many other regional
standards as well.
We continue to expand our
list of compliance offerings
globally to assist our
customers with their compliance
obligations.
So while auditors can sometimes
enter our data centers
to perform these audits, most
people, including Googlers,
cannot.
Under special
authorization, I found out
that our physical
data center security
is built using that defense
in depth foundation.
It's made up of six
layers, from the exterior
all the way to the center,
each increasing in controls
as you get to layer 6.
So I'm going to walk
through each layer and some
of the most notable
features and experiences
that I went through.
So let's start with layer 1.
This is the secure perimeter.
Basically, it means the
property boundaries.
And that includes all
the signage and fencing
around the property.
These are the furthest, most
exterior edges of the property.
So as you drive
into the property,
you'll see signs that might
have a Google logo or a signage.
But otherwise, you really
can't tell immediately
that's-- it's a data center.
It's, more or less--
looks like an industrial
area or a business park.
But things really start
to get interesting
when it comes to layer 2, also
known as the secure perimeter.
And that includes the
main entrance gate.
So I started my
journey by driving up
to this gate, at
which point I needed
my credentials and
my identity checked.
Even before stepping foot
into the property boundaries,
I was already on an
access approval list.
The least privileged
protocol is the idea
that someone should have only
the bare minimum privileges
necessary to perform their job.
So if your least privilege
is to enter layer 2,
then you're not going to
have luck moving to layer 3.
Each person's access
and permissions
are checked at badge readers,
starting with layer 1,
and progresses more
stringently at layer 6.
These exist at every access
point in the data center
facility.
And authorization
measures happen everywhere
using this protocol.
This is something that we don't
just employ in a data center,
but it's also a best
practice we always
recommend for how you set up
your organization resources
and data on Google Cloud.
So as you know, applying
least privilege to IAM roles
on Google Cloud is recommended.
So any user has the bare minimum
roles and their permissions
to perform their functions.
So layer 2 has a lot
of security features,
ranging from smart fencing
to overlapping cameras
to 24/7 guard patrols and more.
And there's actually
a lot more technology
and operations going on behind
the scenes than meets the eye.
So from the time
that you're on-site,
they already know
that you're there.
But what I found
also interesting
is that they're able to do
correlation analysis of where
you've been on site through
cameras, badge access
tracking, et cetera.
And there are also
guards in vehicles
and some guards on foot.
As you can see here, there's
also the vehicle crash barrier.
This is designed to stop a
fully loaded truck from crashing
through the front entrance.
This particular black fence
also that you see here
is an anti-climb fence.
So there are spikes
pointed outward.
It'd be pretty hard to get
over that in one piece.
It's also equipped with fiber.
The technology tells data
center security operations
if someone's near the
fence or touches the fence.
They also use thermal
cameras and standard cameras
so that they're able to see
video footage at night just
as clearly as they
can during the day.
Each camera overlaps the
area that it can cover.
So there's no blind
spots anywhere
around the data center.
Now, you might be
wondering, well,
what if somebody skydives
into the property
or digs under the ground?
Trust me, they have enough
coverage of the area
that they will detect
something coming
into the property
or motion that's
occurring near the fence.
These are not only
physical safeguards,
but act as a big
deterrent to anyone
even thinking about trying
to forcibly come inside.
And more obstacles
await them inside.
And we have additional
operational monitoring
happening in any case that
will alert more guards
to take action if
they detect something.
Layer 3 is building access.
In this case, I was
able to enter the lobby.
But just so you
know, this is still
nowhere near the
data center floor
because that's still a
few more layers deep.
So let's say that you've
gotten through the gate,
you've come inside, you've
come into the secured lobby,
and you have your card or a
form of identification, which
is checked by a receptionist
to make sure that you're
on the access control list.
But what happens if
you lose your card?
Then what?
For that reason, biometric
scanning is also employed.
So, yes, I did have to
get my irises scanned.
Similar to concepts in
software development,
biometric scanning is for
authentication of identity.
Meanwhile, my badge allowing
access to a certain area
is authorization.
Yes, this also felt
like I was on some sort
of secret top mission, maybe
"Mission Impossible" or maybe
"Ocean's Eleven"
or, more recently,
I've been hearing it's
been compared to Professor
from "Money Heist."
But once that was taken
care of, another rule
exists at the data
center that prevents
a vehicle or an
individual closely
following another to gain
entry into a restricted area
without a badge swipe.
So if the system detects
a door open for too long,
it immediately alerts
security personnel.
Any gate or door must close
before the next vehicle
or the person can badge
in and then gain access.
You've probably seen
dual authentication
when you try to
sign into an account
and you get a one-time
password sent to your phone.
We take a similar
approach at the data
centers to verify a person's
identity and access.
At some layers in
the data center,
you're required to
swipe your badge
and then enter a circle
lock or a tubular doorway.
You walk into this
special half-portal
that checks your badge and
scans your eyes to gain access
to the next layer
of the data center.
It prevents anyone from
closely following you
through because only one person
is allowed into the circle lock
at a time.
So you can see here that I
have to first badge, then
step inside, get
my irises scanned,
and then it verifies my identity
and the door on the other side
unlocks.
And something not shown
in the video that I made
is the facility loading
docks, which are
a special section of layer 3.
They're used to receive and
send shipments of materials,
like new hardware.
Truck deliveries from vendors
must be approved for access
to layer 3 to enter the dock.
For security, the
loading dock room
is physically isolated from
the rest of the data center.
And a guard is present--
a guard presence
is required when
a shipment is received or sent.
I actually got super lucky
when I was there and got
to witness shipments being made
of new servers being delivered.
And in order for them
to even get to layer 3,
they had to have been on
the allowed access list
through layers 1 and 2
before arriving at layer 3.
Guards checked their
identification and the access
list before letting them into
layer 2 and, subsequently,
opening the garage door to let
them back up into the loading
dock room.
Then out came fresh new
server racks, one by one.
And once unloading was
complete, the vendor left
and the hardware
operations team began
to move the racks into layer
4 by badging themselves in,
one at a time, with the actual
hardware going into the data
center.
Badge checks occur
at every entry point
throughout the
facility to ensure
least privilege is adhered to.
Even timed
authorizations happen.
So you can do your job for only
an allotted amount of time.
So this could apply to loading
docks or even performing
hardware maintenance on
the data center floor.
You're probably thinking
of your favorite movie,
wondering, what if supply
chain gets intercepted?
Well, additional checks happen
for this potential risk.
And we have tested for
many potential risk
scenarios, which I'll talk
about in a little bit.
Layer 4 is once you've actually
entered the data center itself.
And this includes an extremely
important part of data center
security, the Security
Operations Center, or SOC,
a hive of activity that's
monitoring the data
center 24/7, 365 days a year.
The doors, the cameras, the
badge readers, iris scan--
everything is
monitored from here.
Anyone on site at
the facility will
have their movement patterns
tracked throughout the property
via their badge
and biometric scans
at entry points and doors.
If a door is kept open for
too long or correlation
analysis finds that
their presence is
in an unauthorized location,
alerts will be sent to the SOC
instantly.
This is the brains of
the security system.
So if there's anything out
of the ordinary happening,
they have to be able
to pick that up.
The SOCs of all
Google data centers
are also designed to
roll up to a regional SOC
for multi-regional
high-availability purposes.
If an on-site SOC
were to be disrupted
due to an event, such as a
natural disaster or emergency
building evacuation,
monitoring instantly
rolls over to the regional SOC
for continuous, uninterrupted
monitoring.
SOCs act as a center
for emergency and safety
response in addition to
security responsibilities.
These SOCs monitor
and respond to alarms
at all of our facilities
and are constantly
tracking local and global events
that could impact operations
at our data centers.
Think of this like
high availability
for physical security.
And really, that also means
it's high availability
for logical security and
data protection as well.
Layer 5 is the
data center floor.
Servers and network equipment
that power Google live here.
Security in this layer is one
of the most highly restrictive,
as it's where the data resides.
And this meant I needed
to enter a circle lock,
get my irises scanned
and badge checked.
And then once in there, I
was accompanied by our guards
in every space.
And the VP of global
data centers, Joe Kava,
took me around.
So only hardware operations
personnel, security
professionals, and
key people granted
access on an as-needed
basis can enter.
Access is limited to the
time required to complete
the necessary job function.
So this is truly an
as-needed-only access area,
meaning that only the
technicians and engineers that
have to be there to
maintain, upgrade, or repair
the equipment are
ever allowed there.
This layer is protected by a
circle lock, as I mentioned,
security staff, and
badge-protected doors.
And the data center floor
features laser beam intrusion
detection.
Additional cameras are also
placed throughout the area
while security staff monitor the
data center floor at all times.
And the technicians who
have access to the devices
are there.
But the data at
rest is encrypted.
And you can also issue and
keep your own encryption keys.
And if you're
wondering, Googlers
do not have access to the data
unless you've authorized it
for a technical issue.
And this is called
access transparency,
which is a technical control.
It produces immutable logs any
time a Google administrator
needs to enter a customer's
tenant to perform something,
whether it's a support
request or maintenance.
And you control what types of
access that you want to permit.
For example, maintenance is OK.
Support's not, or it's OK for a
given set of your environment.
So layer 6 is disk destroyal
or, as I like to call it,
hard drive graveyard.
So Google employs a
strict equipment chain
of custody monitoring,
meaning that we meticulously
track the location and the
status of all equipment
within our data center.
This means that we track
the location and status
of every hard drive, from
acquisition to destruction,
using bar codes and asset tags.
These asset tags are scanned
throughout a hard drive's
lifecycle in a data
center from the time
that it's installed
to the time that it's
removed from circulation.
And tracking these
hard drives closely
ensures that they don't
go missing or end up
in the wrong hands.
We also make sure hard
drives are properly
functioning by doing
frequent performance tests.
If a component fails to
pass a performance test,
then it's deemed
no longer usable.
So to prevent any
sensitive information
from living on that disk, then
we remove it from inventory
to be erased and destroyed
in layer 6, disk erase.
Disks enter layer 6 through a
secure two-way locker system,
allowing only
authorized personnel
to retrieve it in layer 6,
which you're seeing here.
When a hard drive is
erased and retired,
the disk erase formatter
uses a zero-filling method
that wipes the disk data and
replaces each bit of data
with zeros.
And we try to recycle
drives and their components.
But if a drive can't
be erased, then it's
stored securely until it
can be physically destroyed,
as you can see here.
And it'd be pretty
impossible to recover
any data from these drives.
And even if anyone tried to take
anything out of the data center
floor with them, we also
have metal detectors
and video surveillance to
ensure all personnel exiting
the data center
halls are properly
checked to prevent unauthorized
equipment from leaving
the floor.
If you're wondering what
happens to this waste,
we actually have researchers
in Google's Oklahoma facility
who are looking into methods
of collecting and recycling
rare earth metals
in hard drives.
Data centers are the largest
consumer of hard drives
that contain elements like
neodymium and dysprosium.
These are the same
elements that have
a role in the components
of electric cars.
And there's a great
article to check out
if you want to learn more.
Leaving layers 5 and 6 is
arguably more difficult
than entering, as
each person must
exit through full
metal detection
and detailed examination.
And fun fact-- Google Cloud
also employs a security testing
program where undercover
actors are, in our employ,
attempting to bring hardware
out of the data center.
This helps us constantly test
and improve our physical data
center security techniques.
We actually run dozens
of these drills a year,
paying unannounced,
skilled adversaries
to try to get past
controls by any means
necessary except for violence.
And this includes fake badges,
social engineering, fake UPS
trucks, ladder trucks to
get over the fence, people
hidden in trucks, attempts
in thick fog, everything.
And we usually win.
After every attempt, we actually
run a blameless post-mortem
to improve and make the
next attempt even harder.
And we ensure the strength
of our security controls
and iterate controls as needed.
This is all about building
a culture of security.
So these layers don't stop
at the physical layer.
They extend into our
technology stack that supports
Google Cloud products, too.
So at Google Cloud, we provide
capabilities and assistance
across Google, Cloud,
Workspace, and connected devices
that cover the whole
scope of responsibility.
We have a number of
native security features
that help protect you
from vulnerabilities,
like encryption in
transit and at rest.
And our hardware infrastructure
is custom-designed.
Our servers don't include
any unnecessary components,
like video cards or
peripheral interconnects,
that can introduce
any vulnerabilities.
And the same goes for software,
including low-level software
and our OS, which is a
stripped down, hardened
version of Linux.
Further, we also design and
include hardware specifically
for security, like Titan,
our custom security
chip that we use to establish
a hardware root of trust
in our servers and peripherals.
We build our network
hardware and software
to improve performance
as well as security.
So on Google Cloud, what's the
best way to approach security?
Well, cloud security is
a shared responsibility.
Depending on what cloud
service you're using,
Google Cloud will manage
various parts of security
above what we ensure through
our secure infrastructure.
So customers are responsible
for securing their own workloads
to meet their requirements
and compliance.
When it comes to cloud
security best practices,
there are two sides to it,
preventative and architectural
controls, which are implemented
through architecture and policy
decisions.
And first, we're going to cover
architectural controls, which
include the communication
between services,
how you structure your
resources on Google Cloud,
and permissions.
And then I'll quickly cover
detective controls, which
use monitoring capabilities
to look for drift, anomalous,
or malicious behavior
as it happens.
Let's talk about our
approach to security tooling
on Google Cloud.
We have layers of security
products and blueprints
for you to quickly
get started here.
So from the bottom up,
we have a global scale
technical infrastructure that's
designed to provide security
throughout the entire
information processing
lifecycle at Google.
And this infrastructure provides
secure deployment of services,
secure storage of data, secure
storage with end user privacy
safeguards, secure
communications
between services, and also
secure private communications
with customers over the internet
as well as safe operation
by administrators.
Building on top of the
secured core infrastructure,
the next layer is the
security products,
like Security Command
Center Premium, which
is our security and risk
management platform,
and assured workloads for
securing your government
workloads, which enable you
to secure your deployments.
These form the lowest levels
of the security stack.
And then on top of this baseline
are security foundations
blueprints.
These are security
blueprints which
include Google Cloud
security best practices that
are embedded within them.
So our goal here is
to make it much easier
for you to start and operate
securely on Google Cloud.
They actually enable you to
jump-start your deployments
by handling some of
your key advanced needs
without your teams first needing
to take time out and learn
all of the advanced skills.
They help you set up org
policies as a resource
hierarchy, networking, access,
logging, detective controls,
and then posture
blueprints, which
cover specific sets of
services and workloads.
Blueprints also
come in three tiers,
which differ in their level of
native support and lifecycle
management.
Supported blueprints are created
by the Google security teams
and managed as
products, which are
regular refreshes
and attestation
and testing of the
functionality and resilience.
They're all verified.
So blueprints can be created
by Google teams or partner
teams or even customer teams.
And the key is that the
lifecycle management
and attestation
of fit for purpose
is the responsibility
of the creating team.
And today, they're
offered via Terraform.
So compatible blueprints
can be created by anyone.
The requirement
is just that they
need to be correctly
formatted to operate
through the blueprint
tool chains.
And then we also
have blueprints that
address specific use cases,
like protecting storage buckets
or doing--
protecting BigQuery users, AI
notebooks, or Anthos, even.
So the topmost layer
here is comprised also
of your own web app and API
protection services, analytics,
or even high-performance
computing environments.
So the security
foundations blueprints
provides a strong starting
point for customers
to build and deploy
their organization.
So customers have access
to the opinionated guide
of the full Terraform
repo of automation scripts
to deploy the
foundational landing zone.
And it can be deployed
either at the full org level
or at the folder level
in the hierarchy.
These blueprints provide an
opinionated vetting pattern
for resource hierarchy,
org policies, IAM,
separation of duties, network
architecture, data access
segmentation, logging,
and detective controls
across projects and accounts.
So that way, you can meet
your security compliance
and have a starting point.
And then you can also start
to build your own workloads
and projects on top.
It provides the foundation
upon which you can further
deploy an increasing number
of opinionated Google-created
security posture blueprints
for specific products,
sets of services, and workloads.
And we update these blueprints
on a six-month cycle.
We also provide a project
factory Terraform module
that enables you to
set the parameters
and constraints for projects
when they are created.
You can access the latest
reference guide, PDF,
and the Terraform scripts repo
from the Google Cloud Security
Best Practices Resource Center.
And here, in addition to the
curated set of Google Cloud
security blueprints,
you can also
access both the
Google BeyondProd
paper, which lays out the
principles and practices
of Google's approach for
Cloud-native security
and how we think about and
how we operate Cloud-native.
For customers who want to
dive deeper into the knowledge
and experience that Google
has, then the Resource Center
also includes a link to
our building security
and reliable systems
reference book.
Additionally, a range
of detailed background
white papers around
our reference materials
is available to customers
from that Resource Center.
And it covers topics like
infrastructure design
and how encryption at
rest and in transit
are handled on Google Cloud.
On the preventative
side, we also
launched Security
Command Center.
This is the canonical
security and risk
database for Google Cloud.
So it includes a risk
dashboard and analytics system
for surfacing, understanding,
and remediating
Google Cloud security and data
risk across your organization.
So this means from
one dashboard,
you can uncover
common web application
and vulnerabilities, like
cross-site scripting or
outdated libraries in
your web applications
running on App Engine,
GKE, and Compute Engine.
And you can also
detect threats using
logs running in Google Cloud
or common container attacks,
including suspicious binary
or suspicious library
and reverse shell.
Security Health Analytics is a
vulnerabilities dashboard here.
And it helps you view
security misconfigurations
by severity, compliance
standards, or project.
And you can take
action from there.
So with this, you can take
inventory of your Google Cloud
assets and partner solutions.
You can also understand exactly
what changed in your asset
history in near real time and
respond to the most pressing
issues first.
You can also receive
notifications
about new findings or updates
to findings within minutes
and be able to take action.
And also, you can identify
security misconfigurations
in your Google Cloud
assets and resolve them
by following actionable
recommendations
that they actually have there.
Lastly, you can catch
web vulnerabilities
before they hit production and
reduce your exposure to risks
and identify compliance-- so see
violations in your Google Cloud
assets and resolve them
with these recommendations.
And of course, you want
to be able to export them.
So you can export
compliance reports
to ensure all your resources
are meeting your compliance
requirements.
We have support for
compliance standards,
like Payment Card
Industry, which
is PCI, the International
Organization
for Standardization, ISO.
There's National Institute of
Standards and Technology, NIST,
and the Center for
Internet Security, CIS,
1 and 1.1, and benchmarks.
This industry-leading
threat intelligence
detects threats
using logs running
in Google Cloud at scale.
And it also uses
kernel-level instrumentation
to identify potential
compromises of containers
and, lastly, combines
threat intelligence
from first- and
third-party providers
to better protect
your enterprise
from costly and
high-risk threats.
Thank you so much for
joining this session.
I know there's a
lot packed in there.
So I hope you found it
as much of an adventure
as it felt like
to go through it.
If you do want to
learn more, check out
the resources that we'll
include for this session.
And always feel free to
reach out to me on social,
like on Twitter, @stephr_wong.
Thanks again.